and so in this talk I'm gonna give you a
brief overview well actually about half
the talk will be based on what I did in
my thesis the high-level takeaways from
that and then the second half of the
talk is going to look at some
preliminary work and hopefully it
inspires you to do maybe some mechanical
design in your robotics so today I'm
talking about hands in the real world in
the lab you can select the objects
you're interacting with you can protect
your robot and you can fix it when it's
broken
all those things are not true anymore
when you're in an unstructured
environment and if we want our robots to
do dexterous manipulation we need our
hands to be resilient because they're
extended from our body and in fact their
job is to hit the world right their job
is to contact the world and so you
imagine they're going to be stressed
very easily with lots of very high
contact forces okay
so first I'm going to start with the
human hand because people have been
inspired by the human hand for centuries
and in this system we have a lot of
moving parts we've got input commands
that result in some behavior some motion
are forces that behavior results in
information gathering so tactile sensing
from our skin and then that combination
of behavior and sensing leads to haptic
understanding of the environment and all
of these are really important areas in
robotic control design understanding of
manipulation my interest has always been
in the system design this is how many
fingers do you have do you have a
squishy skin what sorts of sensors have
you included and this is a system design
question that will influence all of
these areas of control and understanding
and so I created the embodied dexterity
group and so that's like embodied
intelligence is sort of the what what
capabilities does the body have
naturally to be well matched with what
you want to do and obviously dexterous
manipulation so one thing that we can
learn from looking at the human system
is that under actuation might be a good
way to go when we're designing hands
that are able to do many different tasks
so here is a pretty famous study and
there's been
you know extensions of this work since
then but what they did is they looked at
the way that people use their hands the
different sorts of grips that they
perform and then they did a principal
component analysis and looked at the
first couple few principal components
and found that they're actually really
good at describing a vast majority of
the grasps that people use so that
indicates that maybe just a very small
number of actuators is enough to perform
a wide variety of grasps and that's with
a device that has many many degrees of
freedom so under actuation is a useful
tool of course people have known this
for a long time whether intuitively or
explicitly this is a patent from 1919
I've been presenting this all year
because it's exactly a century ago so
it's a lot of fun and this is known as
like the first hand patent and it's
under actuated which is kind of cool so
here's the profile and here's the top
down view here's a profile of one finger
we've got three joints and we've got a
single spring going through it and a
single tendon so when we pull that
tendon it curls up like this so that's
one actuator and three joints and then
when we go one abstraction layer higher
we've got four fingers and they are all
being actuated by a single tendon and it
shares loads between them's with this
like pulley device so if one finger
moves back the others will move forward
and this is I think a pretty clever
mechanism so people have been pretty
good at thinking about this for a long
time but of course there are a lot of
new under actuated hands and this is a
slide courtesy of Mark this is a really
nice way of describing sort of the
variety of under actuated hands that we
see so we've got some that are extremely
precise maybe it's a very low degree of
under actuation and then we have some
that are really really compliant and
flexible really good at conforming to
really odd shapes and so this is still
an active area of research and in part
it's because today we have
miniaturization we have access to new
electronics that's something we didn't
have a century ago we have computing
ability that can influence how we come
up with new
designs how we do simulations we can now
have numerical models for what's going
on and we can come up with new
perception and control strategies and
then finally we have new materials so we
can come up with cell row which is
softer robotic solutions and we can also
let's say come up with new actuators and
so the B is really I think summarized
pretty well the the active areas of
research that are still ongoing and that
do very much influence our creation of
under actuated designs okay so those
designs while while probably intended
for outside the lab they are largely
being tested inside a laboratory
environment so what I'm really
interested is what happens when we start
to apply these in the field there are
extra challenges that we need to
overcome and compliance is really
helpful because if you smash into
something you will passively very
quickly get out of the way essentially
and so we start to see a lot of under
actuated designs these are the ones that
are for ocean exploration and it's a
relatively small number and they have a
lot of specialization so this is
probably the most recent one that's
highly specialized it's a very soft
noodley finger design that grips on to
jellyfish and this sort of design will
only really work underwater
because you have buoyancy if you're out
of out of the water your fingers will
sag and you won't be able to actually
grasp very much stuff um but yeah so
it's a relatively small number I think
there's a lot of really rich space to
explore new designs for this sort of
field operation and despite these trends
we still see that most of the grippers
that are used in the field are these
really simple rigid parallel jog rippers
they are extremely reliable and they
will break the world before they break
themselves and that's something that
really risk adverse applications desire
but in this range here so in the last
five years five plus years there's this
big jump in the design of adaptive and
soft adaptive hands
and I think it's because people are
challenging themselves to apply
multi-finger articulated hands outside
the lab okay so that pretty much gives
context there and then just to define
this really clearly if you have a fully
actuated hand you can control the
degrees of freedom to either have a
certain motion or force but that's not
true anymore with an under actuated
design because the way they interact
with the environment changes the
behavior that means that you need to
very carefully design the passive
mechanism and that leads to this like
ballooning of many different solutions
so when we start to think about what our
under actuated hand is going to be for a
particular application two very
important elements is compliance this is
whether you use silicone rubber versus
steel and also how you distribute
compliance and here's an example of two
identical hands except the distribution
of the compliance and the joints is
mixed up so two very different hands
based on that one parameter and now
contact conditions most people think of
this as coefficient of friction that's
actually kind of a poor predictor of
contact conditions in some circumstances
but I also think that contact location
where contact is likely to occur that's
also an important element of contact
condition again we have an example we
have a very slippery object and it gets
pushed out of the hand and a very
frictional object and it remains in the
hands so that's very important okay so
in summary we're very sensitive to these
elements and while we need to select
them in the design of a new hand if
we're able to alter these conditions
even a little bit during operation we
can now dramatically influence the
behavior so I think that if you're able
to let's say switch a joint from stuff
soft to stiff now you you essentially
have two very different hands and so
being able to adjust these during
operation is a great opportunity and
under actuated hands typically are used
for grasping and holding and rely on the
arms to do most of the manipulation
some people have looked at in hand
manipulation like this with under
actuated devices but it's a much smaller
set of the overall work okay so under
actuated hands
now I'm gonna structure the talk into
these two sections the design of
compliant elements into under actuated
hands in particular for ocean
exploration and for the design of
wearables on the human hand and then the
design and control of contact conditions
firstly I'm going to talk about the
ocean one project and then I'm going to
talk about two very new projects that
still have ways to go but I think have
some new interesting results okay so
who's heard of the ocean one project
everybody
I assume that Osama has given a talk at
some point since you all have been here
so Osama Khateeb is the director of this
project and I was lucky enough to be
here when I was getting started and his
vision is to have this very intuitive
avatar so that a person up on the ship
can actually feel like they're in the
environment touching and interacting
with it even though it's it's remote and
so that's why it has this like cool
humanoid form my job was to design the
hands so I created this last little
section here and it was really fun right
before I graduated we actually took the
robot to the Mediterranean and took it
down to a shipwreck called la lune and
we acquired a vase and it was really
scary because I knew that if these hands
broke we couldn't do anything useful we
can do any manipulation right so the
hands really cannot break and that was a
central part of the design okay so back
here
compliance and contact conditions first
I'm going to talk about sort of these
spring elements down here so here's the
hand design there's a single input shaft
here we've got three fingers and each
finger has three joints so it's it's
very under actuated and we want this to
be able to wrap around extruded objects
so something long and thin like a tool
or a structure but if we can't do that
we also need to be able to perform pin
so if something is too small or too
large for us to wrap our fingers around
part of doing this is thinking about the
compliance of the fingers so here are
the three fingers we've got the tendons
in blue and when we pull on these the
finger will curl up we decided to you
know design the compliance of the flexor
joints very carefully and what we did is
we use this pre tension spring to create
a preload and then as it curls the
affective moment arm decreases and we
get a nice D aggressive spring it's a
useful way to get very stiff behavior
but make it so that is not too hard to
close the hand so if you're interested
in learning more reading the paper
describes it really well what I actually
want to talk about though is these
Springs down here and this is the
transmission that shares loads between
the fingers so let's think about what
happens if these get really stiff let's
say we actually make them rigid does
anybody have any idea what that's or a
guess as to what that's going to do to
the hand when you're trying to grasp
onto something okay is it mean that all
of the tendons have to move in the same
way they all have to change the length
the same amount of length so you're
creating a sort of a positional
constraint a length constraint on all of
the fingers if these become really soft
infinitely soft you go to the other side
of the spectrum and now all of the
tendon tensions have to be that the same
that's a force constraint so by toggling
by changing this one parameter the
stiffness of load sharing you go from a
position constraint to a force
constraint so what do we want this to be
though what does this mean for grasping
well here's an example we've got a tube
and we're pulling it out of the hand and
you can see that this is the there's
only one finger that's resisting the
pullout and we want to make sure that
this finger can hold on as hard as it
possibly can and so we want this to be a
stiff transmission because if we're
going to open this finger we want to
have to open all the fingers we want
this to be really hard to do and you can
see that in this plot the stiff
transmission and
holds on much better than the softest
transmission in blue and it's not
exactly three times but you're getting
approximately that order of scaling so
stiffer is better in this case holding
on to less a structures and tools there
are of course counter examples though so
here I like this one because it's I
think pretty obvious so you've got this
water goblet and it has this thin
feature here a stem you want the fingers
to curl and sort of interlock with that
geometry in order to resist the pull out
forces in this direction and so in this
case we see that the soft transmission
in blue is stronger than the stiff
transmission in pink so just because
your your tendons are stiff doesn't
actually mean that your hand is
necessarily in its strongest
configuration okay so I'm not going to
go into this but empirically given a
very small set of objects I observed
that there's this trend where often we
want either to have the very softest or
the very stiffest transmission possible
in these cases you can see that the
intermediate stiffness in green pretty
much gives intermediate performance a
lot of the time so this is not something
I've proven probably has a lot to do
with the friction and interesting things
going on in the hand so I do think this
is an area for potential future research
to see if this is true over a larger set
of objects but given this assumption we
decided to come up with a mechanism that
did both the softest and the stiffest so
we use these torsional Springs as a
torsional spring flexes it changes its
diameter and so what you can do is put
hard stops or constraints around that
spring to define under what loads it's
going to be stopped soft and what loads
is going to be stiff and so when our
hand is open in this beginning pose and
we start to rotate the shaft to wind up
our tendons we can decide whether we're
going to start soft whether we're going
to start stiff and then if you start
soft you can still transition into stiff
later if you have a hard stop on the
inside
again if your if you didn't quite catch
that and you're interested the paper
does talk about it and when we were
doing this in the field I I just I could
sleep a little bit better at night
knowing that we could choose to put this
in a soft mode when we needed to so not
only does the softness of the tendon
give you more strength in certain
circumstances but also if you take a
string if you take a string like this
and you shock it that's one of the
worst-case scenarios for snapping a
tendon and as this finger is coming into
this box it kind of smacks down on to
onto the top of it and having that
compliance is going to make it more
forgiving so that was one useful
consequence and then just to show that
we were able to in fact do the pinching
here is this and once again we see the
operator isn't really necessarily paying
attention to this hand right so we want
this to not break we want this to be
probably in the soft mode but this one
we're lifting a heavy object with one
finger we want this one to be stiff okay
so that summarizes the compliance
selection of the ocean one hand now I'm
going to move on to contact conditions
underwater this is the object that we
acquired from V shipwreck and it's
covered in this really thick slimy
biofilm and you can almost see how it
feels by the way that these people are
holding on to it right so they're kind
of caging it from all different
directions so if this was really
frictional we'd probably just hold it
like this but because it's slippery
they're kind of doing this interesting
grasp and caging is a term for sort of
geometrically constraining an object
even if you have no friction so sort of
approximating this one analogy would be
a bar of soap that's maybe been sitting
in water for a while it's really kind of
goopy and slippery and you can see that
without suction with this particular
hand we're not able to pick it up I
guess we could put spikes on it but now
you're like spiking your soap so instead
what you can do is add a little bit of
suction flow to the fingertips which
means that the object is going to be
to that location and you're able to pick
it up now I'm talking about a really
light amount of flow rate this is
approximately how much flow rate we're
talking about so it's really gentle and
so this is not a suction cup we don't
have like a cup that's actually creating
a seal a seal could occur but it's not
necessary also what we're gonna do
because this is so light is rely on the
strength of the hands in the arms to do
most of the manual tasks and we're
really just using this suction flow to
enhance that contact to make it a little
bit easier now one thing that's really
nice about suction is it attracts
objects to a very convenient location on
the hand so this is where I'm getting to
this expansion of what contact
conditions mean contact conditions have
to do with what happens before contact
even occurs where is that going to
happen and instead of having to fish
around for this object the object comes
to us and this was the first take I just
tossed in this neutrally buoyant object
and it went to where it needed to go
okay so that seems a little obvious so
what about larger and more massive
objects when does this stop being
helpful under what circumstances
shouldn't we include suction and what I
really wanted to ask is what's the role
of water drag an object inertia on the
usefulness of this mechanism we didn't
realize this at first but it it became
obvious that this is actually a
bio-inspired mechanism pretty much all
fish use suction feeding meaning oh no
the video stopped meaning they open
their mouth they suck in water and in
with it comes to prey that's not an
evolutionary trait you see very much on
land right like we don't go up to our
pasta and go you know just like expect
it to come into our mouth right we use a
fork but being underwater being in a
denser and more viscous fluid right that
starts to make this advantageous so I
well I'm not going to go over it because
it's preliminary work and I don't want
to steal my students thunder we do have
an ongoing grant looking at fish as
inspiration for graspers and the
laterz okay so moving on to this
question of what about more massive
objects what about larger objects well
here's a tube and it's really far away
from the center of the palm without
suction we have no hope it's not going
to happen with suction we have hope and
so if our controller isn't perfect if we
have a last-minute disturbance that
we're not over able to overcome we're
still going to have a chance at grasping
this object so in order to understand
this better we created a model the dots
are experimental data that's that we're
using to validate the model and then the
lines are the models themselves this one
here this solid blue line is grasping
under water where we include water drag
on the object that's in comparison to
this red line where we ignore water drag
on the object so this would be like
approximately grasping in space versus
grasping in a still pool of water so
actually having a little bit of water
drag makes your life a little bit easier
makes you grasp region bigger and so
this is the hand and this is the initial
displacement of the object and then when
we add suction we get an increase of
about a third of our grasp region and so
we get this again a little bit more
forgiving grasp region so now maybe our
controller doesn't have to be quite as
perfect or maybe we can go into slightly
harsher environments and still grasp
stuff and once we come up with a model
we can now do some really interesting
parametric studies because those
experiments for really time expensive
and here we have varying the pump
parameters so here this blue dot this is
the line for the pump I showed you the
experimental pump that we had and here
is changing the tube mass you can see
that we get the most benefit from an
increase in the pump parameters flow
rate and pressure in this intermediate
region and so let's say we're grasping
an object of one kilogram we really
would benefit a lot from increasing our
suction parameters if we're only
grasping really
massive objects or really really light
objects either we want no flow or just a
little bit of flow is going to do the
job so I think that's a really kind of
interesting design observation and
that's what takes this from just an
experimental validation to a design
question okay and just for fun what if
we turn the flow around so now we're
reducing our contact we're reducing our
normal force maybe adding some
lubrication and we take this balloon
which we couldn't grasp just by
squeezing and instead now we're able to
sort of push it up into the hand and
successfully grasp it and again just
because we had now have suction what
else can we do with this and in fact if
you measure the flow rate going through
the tube it's going to be clogged and
unclogged as you make contact with an
object and break contact with an object
and you can monitor that flow rate so
you can monitor clogging but you also
know where your orifice is located right
so you know where that contact is
occurring on your hand so this is
starting to sound like a tactile sensor
now tactile sensing it's pretty much
just really useful for robots I think we
all know physics pretty well so you can
all deduce that my thumb is in contact
even if you can't see that but a robot
might not be able to figure that out
right away so having some sort of touch
sensing could be really helpful but also
underwater it can be murky your hand
could be occluded there's a lot of
reasons why you would want to talk to
all sensing okay so here we've got a
fingertip here's where the orifice is
located it's going to curl up against
the surface and the blue line is
estimating what the angle between the
surface and the fingertip is the red
line is a differential pressure because
that's a differential pressure
transducer that's measuring head loss
across a tube which gives us an estimate
of flow rate so as we come into the
surface we see this big drop in flow and
then as we curl up we get these dynamics
signals kind of spikes during the
stick-slip events it saturates and then
as we come down and bounce
off we get another very dynamic signal
here so here you're getting the signal
where you have sort of this nice
analogue slow steady state signal but
you also have these dynamic events
superimposed on top that's not something
we've done anything with yet but I do
think it's a cool area it's a really
complex signal which is different from a
lot of sensors that you usually would
want to integrate with a hand but it's
very rich okay so I'm not going to go
into this too much again it's under
review but what we did is we started to
try and validate whether this tactile
sensor would be helpful for grasping so
this last student this last summer I had
a student who looked at if you could
monitor flow rate to estimate the force
of pulling the object out of the hand so
he had a load cell he came down he
grasped the object and pulled up and
then quote used machine learning to see
if he could estimate pull off force with
suction alone and he was actually able
to do okay for a first pass and I'm
definitely thinking that this will be an
area for more research to come yeah I
think that's all I want to say about
that and I think it makes sense
especially in an under actuated hand
because your hand is going to move as
you pull on the object right you're
going to get deformation and this clog
sensor is measuring a change in the
orientation between the finger and the
object okay so that summarizes pretty
much my thesis plus a little bit so now
for the second half of the talk what I
want to do is introduce some new ideas
some new projects that are ongoing but
are already enough to to show our
initial observations and the first one
is still in contact conditions but now
we're handling coral reefs we're
handling pieces of coral so how does
that change what we want to do at that
contact and what we find is that fun
blunt spines are a useful solution then
under the umbrella of compliance we're
now designing soft gloves for people
with spinal cord injury or just weakness
of the hands so how do we choose
compliance such that it's helpful for
the
person so let's start with the quarrel
grasping the ocean one project that I
showed was a pretty big platform you
need a crane you need a team you need a
crew in order to deploy it and even
though it's much smaller than the usual
standard for something like an Bari so
doc Ricketts is this huge machine you
need an incredible amount of
infrastructure so what we want to do is
enable very small vehicles one that I
could lift up on my own to do really
useful tasks like sampling coral reefs
that we can understand them better
there's a problem with small platforms
though they're really hard to control
they have less thrust their moment arms
aren't quite as large and so they're
really hard to control when you have a
very turbulent environment so this is
courtesy of the kal Academy of science
they have this little Rover with a
gripper on it and they're trying to
grasp this thing we watched it for
probably a half an hour eventually we
kind of smashed into it break it a whole
lot and then swim away without a sample
and so this can be really frustrating
this is in comparison to people doing
the same task so here we just want a
little snippet and so she's gonna come
in and break off a little piece and here
we have just a little sample that's all
that we need really to do many of the
biological tests so one strategy that
people can take in order to stabilize
their body is to hold on to the
environment and robots can do this when
the ground is flat right they can sit
down on the ground but they can't
necessarily do that on a vertical wall
so what we want to do is create an
anchor so we have our small blue ROV -
it comes in at grasps onto the
environment in order to do a much more
precise tasks such as fracturing the
coral and then we can swim away with a
sample this is a multi-faceted problem
so we're looking at the mechanical
design of the grasper and the sampling
mechanism but there are people who are
interested in the genetics so this is
Cal Academy of Science and then we have
also people who are looking at the
vehicle dynamics and control of this
sort of platform and so when we want to
grip onto corals we start by looking at
corals
do they look like and they have this oh
and so I do want to specify we're
looking at very deep corals ones that
are in the meso photic region and
because there's very little light they
tend to grow in these very thin fragile
plates and so we're assuming it's gonna
be this plate like structure which means
we're gonna be able to pinch on to it
it's highly reduced it has these large
sort of like mountainous features and
they have a relatively regular size and
shape now spines make a lot of sense
when you're gripping onto burgos and
rough objects such as this crab it's got
little spike feet and it sort of hugs
onto onto rocks we are certainly not the
first people to start looking at spines
in fact it was spearheaded here and so
here we've got a little squirrel
inspired claw feet and then we've got
spiny bot here that's able to climb and
and so micro spines have been around for
a long time but recent work has found
that when you get really good at
engaging with a surface with spines the
way they fail is actually the material
breaking off so the issue is when you're
handling corals which might be very
brittle and fragile that's gonna be your
failure mode so how do you get around
that and so our hypothesis right now
given that we know the surface is that
actually blunt teeth work really well as
long as you're able to interlock with
that surface you don't want to be too
sharp because you'll actually induce
early fracture so we went with this very
simple 3d printed rotational spine
design because we're doing a post
pinching we have these sets that
interlock with the surface so we can
grip on to it
we sort of do a centering behavior and
then as we swim forward our spines open
up and interlock with this surface so
we're sort of latching in this one
directional way so once we grip on in
this way once we pull backwards we're
not going to come off now the choice to
use rotational spines does have some
consequences one the way the reason why
we wanted to go with this as we said
well whenever there's a valley when we
have a
spine that's really well engaged with
the surface we want that one to squeeze
harder so if you have this constraint
and you assume that it can rotate freely
you're going to have this relationship
between the angle of your spike and how
hard you squeeze so once again the spike
that's down in the valley is going to
squeeze harder the problem though is you
have this interesting singularity and so
if your angle becomes too steep you now
are pushing so hard that you pry your
jaws apart and so that was one failure
mode for this gripper it's 3d printed
plastic it's very compliant but despite
all of these challenges and the fact
that this is very preliminary we're able
to hold on to real meza photic coral
samples with up to almost 60 Newton's of
force it's quite a lot given this very
cheap $10 3d printed design and so the
failure modes are usually sheering off
the surface features we need to explore
what happens once we have goopy coral
tissue there and then also when the
spines break which was more what we saw
in the field so we've done two field
experiments one was with the handheld
device some divers did some testing we
had our blue ROV that went down to the
Caribbean and then this upcoming March
were going to Moorea there's a Berkeley
field station in French Polynesia and at
that point we're hoping to have our
braking sampling mechanism ready
hopefully we have a fully integrated
machine and of course the biologists are
very concerned about well when you're
handling these very fragile ecosystems
are you doing damage and so we're going
to work with them to understand the
implications long-term of us actually
handling these reefs okay so then the
very final project is this glove and
it's designed to help people with spinal
cord injury and once again look at
features of compliance and how we've
designed it into this machine so the
motivation is that there are a lot of
people with spinal cord injury living in
the United States alone and for people
who have tetraplegia which is some
degree
paralysis in the hands and arms if you
survey them they say that regaining some
function of the hands and arms is one of
their top priorities this is on the same
level as let's say urinary and bowel
function right so this is a very basic
human capability that is really valued
and there have been a number of gloves
that have been designed so here are some
recent ones you can see they're like
2017 to 2019 and I believe that all of
them have at least stated that spinal
cord injury injury could be one
potential application most of them have
a lot of compliance softness some
interesting linkages and interesting
actuators now this is in the context of
commercially available gloves and other
sorts of hand orthotics and basically
45% of people with spinal cord injuries
say they they essentially never use
their device so there's this big gap
between what's available now and what
people need so this is the design that
that we came up with it's a sheet of
spring steel that goes across the dorsal
part of the hand to the back of the hand
we've got a distal flexor here there's a
rigid support that rigid support is this
portion right here so it goes across the
bottom part of the fingers and it's a
very sparse design and so this palm
glove which supports the thumb and also
protects and adds friction to the palm
here this device can be put on top of
this and this is a very very common
device that people use and when we
tested this on a small number of healthy
individuals asking them not to flex
their hands they grasped an average of
up to an average of 20 Newtons of force
so that's a pretty strong grip
okay so how do we distribute compliance
on this device when we first started we
wanted this to be extremely simple but
we realized very quickly that a
cantilever beam that's being actuated by
the tip is gonna Bend the most at the
base right and so we needed to add an
extra joint here in order to increase
the curling of the fingers but what we
did find is that this placement along
the fingers was very natural so when you
had a new subject put on the glove they
sort of naturally fit it to themselves
and it worked pretty well so it was
relatively agnostic to individual
variations in finger length or hand size
um and one other really important
element of this is Dawne ability so when
we look back at what those what are
those new devices that are being
developed well they've got some really
awesome new actuators and they they are
really great as research devices but how
is a person with a limp hand with a
paralyzed hand supposed to put on a
glove when I put on gloves I stiffen my
fingers and I grab onto it with my other
hand like this so how are you supposed
to do that without assistance
so in this device we really focused on
having this open surface on the base
where somebody could hook their fingers
very easily and push it on and then it's
pretty much in place except for maybe
two straps that you could do with your
teeth so this was a really important
element that said we haven't
characterized Don ability yet for this
device and in fact that's not a super
well defined parameter and then of
course how do we control this we have a
motor that's opening and closing the
hands how does the operator tell the
device when it wants to open and close
so there's this this behavior called
tenodesis grasping it has to do with the
fact that the tendons that that open and
close your fingers also go past your
wrists so when they elongate across your
wrist your fingers naturally close and
you can actually try this so if you have
your hands sort of down your wrist down
like this and you flex your wrist up it
takes a little bit more effort to do
this then it would just to let your
fingers curl up
right so that's tenodesis grasping and
when somebody's new to spinal cord
injury if they just had one this is an
approach that's actually taught as a
strategy a compensatory strategy in
order to grasp very small objects the
problem is you're now coupling wrist
motion to finger motion and if you have
a constraint a motion constraint at your
end effector that's going to influence
the rest of your arm so if I want to
grip onto this object I have to actually
move my whole body right I can't just
open and close my fingers so we decided
again this is a hypothesis that people
with spinal cord injury would find wrist
flexion as an intuitive way to open and
close the device and I think that you
know this is something that we need to
test but what we'll see whether that's
true or not and but when we ask people
who are healthy who don't have spinal
cord injury to do this you can see
they're a little clumsy so what's next
we just got our first IRB approved to
actually work with individuals with
spinal cord injury I'm really excited
for that because I think we're gonna
it's just going to be a determinist
opportunity to learn and and so we've
got a lot of studies planned for that
and in part this is so I showed you this
study before the principal component
analysis pretty much most of these
studies that are characterized in human
grasping work with a healthy subject
pool they don't necessarily work with
people who have alternative ways of
doing dextrose manipulation so part of
this is going to be recharacterizing
what is dexterity mean for different
individuals okay and then I also teach
an augmenting human dexterity course in
which I learned a lot and the students
learned a lot and I do want to say that
this work was actually done by all
people not in my lab I borrowed students
from a different lab from Professor
Thomas zookas lab the MSC lab but you
can look it up in two publications okay
I went out Lightspeed so this summarizes
the projects that I've been a part of
and I've showed you sort of where my
thesis led to and there's still a couple
open questions there and then some new
areas of
search that I think have just a lot of
potential for growth and the main
takeaway is that when you're designing
mechanisms for the real world you really
do have to consider compliance don't
just go with a fully rigid machine
because it's not going to break there
are ways to make compliant machines not
break and still be very useful and also
contact conditions can make all the
difference I have a great lab there's a
lot of stuff to come in the pipeline the
work of the spine gripper was Monica and
Michael Abbott helped out with the
suction tactile sensing but they are
also doing other projects and there's a
number of first-year students who have
another set of projects going on and so
hopefully if I gave a talk here in
another year there'd be a whole set of
new projects to present so it's it's a
really exciting time in an edge so with
that I'm happy to take any questions so
this is not published work it's it's
actually classwork um some students for
designing prosthetic hands for a kid
named Theo who was born without the
distal part of his his arm after the
elbow and so these are devices that were
were built for him I'm curious about the
suction sensing and support ocean one if
I remember well a lot of the operation
was the operation and a big part of this
was have to keep back do you think it
will be possible to give any sort of
haptic feedback on such end they seemed
like a weird modality to try to transfer
the other operator right yeah that's a
really good question
at 1:00 so let's say the person had a
little like little suction cup that like
contacted their finger I guess and that
might be an intuitive way to sense
suction engagement that would be kind of
a cool a cool setup to try but like I'm
saying so if you're able to correlate
your sensor information with some other
information that's helpful such as
pullout force you could use that
external force measurement and portray
that back in this case for ocean one
they would be redundant because ocean
one has a load cell at the wrist so
really that study was more proof of
concept but a lot of robots do have load
cells so I think probably what you
instead use it for is maybe for internal
forces or some other sort of interaction
that you can't measure with your loads
oh yeah but I think it'd be fun to hook
up little suction cups on a person and
see how it how it is I don't know if
there's any I'm sure there are a suction
style haptic displays out there I just
don't know them all so in regards to the
suction like you mentioned like it's not
a suction cup and might show that
sometimes a bigger pump doesn't help but
would it be helpful do you think so like
make a little rubber ring around it and
try and make it a section covered okay
yeah thank you am I lost over this we
did find even with the tactile sensor
that a soft skin was extremely helpful
so in you imagine okay you're gonna get
the most force when you're clogged and
in that circumstance is going to be
acting like a suction cup so if you're
just trying to like grip onto or like
palm and object your best case scenario
will be a full seal so if you have that
fantastic and then we kind of do that I
would say it's a little bit less
sensitive to bumps and grooves on the
surface so if you have a slightly porous
object a suction cup won't be able to
seal but we will still be able to pull a
pressure differential so I say that the
the fact that it's a flow rate doesn't
negate the suction cup element it almost
expands it into a new regime so yeah and
and the sensor so if you don't have
a soft skin any little misalignment is
going to create a really large flow if
you create a really soft skin you're
going to be able to halfway clog your
orifice over a much larger range of
contact orientations and so it's a
really helpful element for for sensing
because without the skin you could just
miss contact all together yeah cues if
they're considerations doing with the
fact that you're in seawater like you do
you have trouble housing motors and a
containment where it works well and I
don't know if you thought about using
maybe soft actuators but maybe they
don't like hold out hold up well in
seawater yeah I do think that there have
been some people who have tried
exploring different sorts of actuators
on your water so like shape-memory alloy
for example I think it was used in a
little fish robot but the problem is
like when it's in water it starts
bubbling and weird things happen so yeah
definitely being exposed to water will
will change your thermal properties your
conductive properties a lot of elements
and then even in the ocean when you go
deep your your pressure so usually when
you see in these robots is something
that's insensitive to pressure so you've
got incompressible materials or some
sort of differential pressure mechanism
and and then sealing electrical motors
is really common just because the
materials can croud but so for ocean one
it's an oil filled cavity because if you
had air it might like collapse at large
depths so yeah motors can run an oil and
actually some brushless motors if you
treat the materials right can just run
in water but again you have that
long-term aging effect there might be an
issue
yeah yeah
via coral reefs yeah I saw that the
testing was happening on air did the
sample of it yes but was there any
difference in air and the underwater
we didn't explicitly test that yeah I
have an undergraduate researcher trying
to figure out how corals alive in our
labs so we can actually test it with
like the real tissue properties my best
guess is that yeah it has to do with
like having a slimy tissue there might
be really different than like dry bare
coral also the coral might just be more
brittle when it's been dried out I'm not
sure exactly how the coral itself
changes underwater but my guess is
that's going to be the biggest change
yeah cuz the spine behavior is pretty
much static I don't think that should
change too much yeah you did you would
except with a coral underwater in that
one you said that a diver went down yeah
what was the damage that you observed
from that coral during that yes they did
report so that was a biologist so we
were able to they just like during that
imaging where it's like shaking out the
dirt it looks like it's I think I found
it was cool because it was it like we
weren't planning on picking up that
object we had no really probably priori
knowledge of that being there and yet
they just saw it and wanted to pick it
up and it worked
so I guess to me it was cool because I
knew the context that yeah
good good yeah I give this question with
every talk so I was just waiting for
somebody yeah that's going to be a
problem right you're gonna suck up sand
and goop and stuff right there are a
couple strategies we could take so if
we're able to reverse flow if we're
measuring flow rate and we detect a clog
that we know isn't contact we could
reverse the flow and like like evacuate
it out
and you kind of see fish do that like
they'll stuck stuff in sometimes old
like spit it back out could work there's
also other strategies where I think the
scaling is not advantageous for for this
amount of flow but when people are
excavating at shipwrecks what they do is
they essentially pump water through a
tube which creates a negative suction
force this way
and so while your pump is up here the
goop goes up and then this way so you
never actually draw fluid from the
environment through your through your
pump so that's a potential strategy and
then there's other things people do like
kind of have these big chambers where
your goop will come and settle then your
pumps up top so there's like a lot of
different strategies that you could go
about making sure that the stuff doesn't
become a problem but that's certainly
like yeah that's a really important
practical detail so going back to the
coral gripper is it just rigidly
attached to the diver so is there
anything that you plan to do to because
you mentioned it's hard to control or
rotate or something yeah so we're kind
of waiting to hear what the resolution
is gonna be for the the guys doing that
controller of the ROV because we now
have the same one and so we're sort of
sharing code and hardware it's sounding
to me like in in the vertical
displacement they're gonna be able to
get within a small number of centimeters
actually with visual feedback because
you're close to a substrate so you can
get very good detection of motion with a
camera so we're actually thinking it's
gonna be okay without adding more
degrees of freedom an arm or something
but there has been work on like space
gripping and stuff we're like a flexible
wrist or some sort of damped
transmission can be really helpful and I
do think eventually what we could have
is like hopefully you can anchor your
your anchor in a very robust fashion and
then still let your robot kind of swim
around as it needs so yeah I could
definitely see it's decoupling in some
way but as of now we're kind of just
waiting to see what what really is going
to be the need yeah
awesome